there's a strongest in the world my
mother took me in she's kind this
amazing movie has such a unique premise
when you first got the project did you
have any idea we'd be here it's getting
all this award season buzz um when I
first got the project I knew that it was
special because the script was such a
little gem and you I've read enough
scripts in forever to know when
something just is different and kind of
knows what its gonna be you know you
hope that people like it you hope that
it gets all the buzz and excitement and
success but I knew it was gonna succeed
as a film especially with taiko behind
it the way little Roman was here and he
told me he loved working with you so
much because you never made him feel
less than it was so sweet he was like
she was a child star she gets it very
mature in the movie others an imaginary
friend did you ever have an imaginary
friend or is your daughter in that phase
at all um no she doesn't have an
imaginary friend yet I feel I lived in
like a very there was a lot of imaginary
play going on I was just constantly I
think cuz I just loved drama and like
all that was a jazz hands kind of kid
but I didn't really have an imaginary
friend because I had a twin brother and
he was very real that's built-in
Halloween coming up do you guys have
plans how do you and your little lady
celebrate oh I'm deaf I'm hosting a
Halloween party with like 65 year old so
it's so wish me luck
a lot of champagne will be involved not
for me not the five year olds all the
parents last question for you we really
want more closure on Black Widow we
loved her so much what are we gonna get
out of the new movie what are we gonna
get out of the new movie closure I hope
so
do you love it I don't know if I could
take it anymore without any closure it's
too exhausting yeah I love it I'm so
proud of what we made and yeah now we
get to sprinkle the magic all over it
and get it ready for audiences me first
[Music]